[Music]
[Applause]
john smolt's hall of famer he'll be on
the call tomorrow red sox yankees 4
eastern that will be on fox sports one
and john joins us on the program john
tougher to play golf against tiger woods
or michael jordan
well they're both the same in the sense
that
their will to win and talk trash at the
same time is second to none i guess
larry bird would be uh
throw him in there in the basketball
world but um
tougher to play against tiger woods
because he's
almost impossible to beat
how many strokes do you get when you
play against tiger how many do you get
when you play against jordan
so
in the heyday of uh
me being in better shape and tiger being
the number one player in the world
we would have this
fun little match where we'd have three
different matches
he'd give me one aside in one match
two aside in the second match and three
aside in the third match now he would
win about ninety percent of the time in
the one aside
i would win most of the time at three
aside and it always came down to suicide
so i guess the two side was the was the
match that would always come down to
that last hole
and i would say that
most of the times i had a seven to ten
footer to either win the match
or
push the match and he would chuckle and
know that i was probably going to miss
it and i did
what kind of trash talk though are you
getting
oh he's i mean i never would say
like the common mistake everyone would
make when we they play with tiger the
first time they feel like ah you gotta
mix and match and you gotta
you know make yourself feel good by
talking you don't do that you just you
zip it you don't fire up a guy who has
the capability of pushing the pedal down
and um
there was there was only one time that i
i found myself
falling into that trap i my buddy
uh got a hole in one when we were
playing with them and the score card on
the fivesome for the par three
read five four three two one those were
the scores
so i took the ball out of my out of the
hole that my buddy made the hole in one
and i picked it up and i said what's
more believable when we get back home
the fact that you got a hole in one or
that you beat tiger by four on one hole
tiger made the five
and
he gave me a gesture
and proceeded to go 12 under
in the next 22 holes
all i did was make that statement and it
lit a match
and it was like the wildest ride you've
ever seen in your life to try to hang on
of course i didn't win that match
because 12 under and 22 next holes is
pretty tough to beat i don't
i would think jordan would be a better
trash talker than tiger oh no doubt
i mean no doubt because
that's not his sport right i mean
that's
can you do this
john can you
do baseball trash talking making fun of
jordan's baseball career while you're
playing golf against him
no no no no see
i mean
the resumes are so incredible that when
i first played with with michael and he
was still playing for the bulls and i
was just getting going for the braves
okay
i i didn't have a resume there was
nothing to kind of
be proud of especially when your team
loses 100 games every year well
on the last hole of the match we were
playing at in chicago
he's standing over a 30-footer
and he goes this is no big deal
i mean and he starts reciting his resume
six times this four time that
i mean it was impressive just to hear if
someone else was saying and he made the
pot
so now i've got a seven footer to win
the match and i stand over the putt and
i've got
nothing to say i said
losing record we've like you know there
was nowhere to go
luckily i i made the putt but over the
years
there's nobody that wills himself like
that isn't a professional golfer than
michael jordan and he
he will let you have it and it is an
absolute
um it's the it's the greatest grind of
of playing a sport that's not your sport
tigers that's a different atmosphere i
mean for him to talk trash and golf is
like
you know
i mean anybody else just making a layup
so you just stay away from that
but jordan famously loves to play for a
lot of money
jordan jordan will will play for
anything he just doesn't care what it is
he's just going to beat you
well what did you guys did you play for
money
yeah but it's insignificant compared to
to to what his ability to want to win
like
if it's a dollar or it's a billion
dollars it's no different to michael
jordan he he just wants to beat you and
that's the competitive drive
that
we all when we were in our heyday in our
own sport love to be part of right so
when you're doing something else that
you're not known for well that same
competitive drive kicks in and you just
you want to beat whoever you're playing
it doesn't matter and that's what i i'm
telling you i've never seen two
individuals that were more
driven obviously
than those two in their capacity to just
be
dominant and and and love it and
of course just
seeing it play out with with
jordan's documentary and then obviously
what what what tiger's doing it you feel
like
i felt like i didn't there's i mean for
the longest time like i don't belong in
these groups i don't belong in that
sphere of
of excellence that's how
that's how incredible the aura is when
you're around when you're around those
two guys he's john smoltz john will be
on the call red sox yankees that will be
tomorrow 4 eastern on fs1
the uh
pitch com the
keypad for the catcher
uh feels to me like an overreaction to
the sign stealing
controversy your thoughts on if your
catcher had a keypad and was signaling
pitch and location to you on the mound
i think there's more of an issue of
trying to speed the game up than there
is of that there's definitely the
component of trying to eliminate that
business of what we dealt with the years
ago and i think that's fine so whatever
moves the game faster i know you know
the pitch clock's coming but i'll tell
you it's interesting and the day that
we're playing today i would have rather
have it reverse like
in our day we were calling all the
pitches
so it would be better if there was a way
to do it in reverse and you tell the kit
pitcher catcher what's coming so then
there's no reason there's no reason to
shake off right today less guys call
pitches less guys are thinking about
reaction to the hitter what does the
hitter swing look like they're more
robotic with information so it really
encompasses around the catcher to try to
guess or come up with a game plan that
he and the pitcher can be locked in so
that there isn't a lot of time wasted
and shaking signs but if you think about
it and you're the pitcher and veteran
guys probably call most their games you
know what you're going to throw so if
you could give that signal which we did
in a variety of ways with with motions
with the glove or different things that
we coded
so that you didn't have to give signs
then nobody could steal anything okay
wait a minute
take me back to when you're with the
braves so you got maddox and glavin and
you and you're you're calling the game
not javi lopez or whoever was catching
you so how do you how do you signal in
fastball and the location
so there would be ways to do it with
your glove there would be ways to do it
with for example now the catcher still
has to give the suggestion of what he
thinks but you're giving the answer so
if he gets fastball and you want
curveball you can wipe above your belt
to add one you could wipe below your
belt to subtract one there are different
movements you can do um you know from
but for the most part back then you just
wanted to be together
in your calling and most of the times
you were
and
my point is the pitcher knew what he was
going to throw so short of telling the
catcher verbally
he had to still rely on signs and then
those signs
however you shook most people just shook
and waited for the next set of signs but
the problem back then
and the problem even
you know the sequence of signs
on the field you can steal if a catcher
doesn't do a very good job matter you
know the emphatic three down in the
middle of four fingers
sometimes gives it away or the way he
sets up so what this is going to do is
at least eliminate all of that you know
on the field you're not going to be able
to decode unless a pitcher tips or a
catcher's stance dictates what kind of
pitch is coming
when a catcher got wider it's usually an
off-speed pitcher pitch coming when the
catcher got narrow of course it'd be fat
so there's there's little tricks of the
trade but this is a good step in the way
that will allow the game to move faster
and that's really the ultimate goal is
to get the game moving faster so the
sign sequence and the decoding doesn't
take more time away from the action we
moving closer to uh automated strike
zone john
dan i'm fearful we are but i'm going to
i want to put a little caveat in there
that if if it comes into the game they
better be prepared to lower the strike
zone because
what you see on tv let's say is
i don't know 98
accurate that the strike zone box that
you see on your tv
so imagine the top of the strike zone at
98 miles an hour a baseball in its
diameter of course
is going to be bigger than that thin
line if you pitch at the top of the
strike zone with an automatic strike
zone the hitters have no chance
and then you throw in a curveball that
comes to the top i know it's
two-dimensional and the technology is
pretty good
but my fear would be everyone would
think that would give the hitter an
advantage because the strike zone would
get smaller for the pitchers in reality
it would be the opposite because
the pitchers are going to realize
especially the ones that exist today if
i can throw the ball at the top of the
strike zone with velocity and they're
getting that call
it's over so if you lower the strike
zone you give everybody a legitimate
chance to handle the velocity that
exists today and the hitter can then you
know it's more
it's down and it could be a little bit
wider but if it's taller the the
electric strike zone would be so
difficult to hit so is it coming more
than likely but hopefully it comes with
a lower strike zone that that gives
everybody a legitimate chance
and with a lower strike zone by the way
you're going to have less walks i
believe because when everyone's trying
to throw the ball up
to a spot that nobody can hit guess what
happens
walks come into play hit batman's hits
batman's come hit batters come into play
and then the inevitable ball down the
middle because the area of success
is not great up there it would help
every aspect of what i just said
great to talk to you by the way uh john
smoltz led the league in blank category
for three consecutive seasons
john can you guess the category
you led the league
for three consecutive seasons
oh i sure can that would be the wp
category it would be wild pitches yes
yes and i have the record
for
that will never be broken
in all-star game history
i had three wild pitches in one inning
now
in my defense oh boy i came in with the
bases loaded
darren dalton was catching me
not familiar with my stuff
two of them were not my fault i know
that's gonna sound like a cop-out but he
came out and apologized twice
the third one was my fault i i cleared
the bases
those three runs
were charged to my teammate steve avery
and i had to i didn't give up a run
and uh that record i think it can really
only be tied i don't think it'll ever be
broken but i came in with the base
loaded
i left with nobody on base
i didn't give up a run
but i had three wild pitches well
congratulations john
thank you hey great to talk to you and
uh we'll be watching tomorrow red sox
yankees at 4 eastern on fs1 thank you
john
you got it that's john smoltz
yeah those are great ideas those are
great thoughts they really are
i love talking to john